so your first on-air interview was with
Will Smith and Angela yeah I done a lot
of interviews off-camera as a producer
so I had covered junkets but it never
made air I was always behind the scenes
I would do the interview but it was it
was just the part you know just the
person you're talking to but my first
on-air thing was a show called your
movie show with suChin Pak who is a big
VJ at MTV and they sent me to LA and I
interviewed Will Smith and Jack Black
and Angelina Jolie and had a half-hour
each with them this is Fran and uh yeah
it kind of little fired me to say wow
this is really fun to see a movie and
then sit down with the stars and talk to
them about whatever I want to this is
great
but I've never been on TV before so do
it on MTV how big eight was a lot and
then I didn't really do much with MTV
afterwards so that was incredibly
humbling at that time because he showed
me how quickly it can all just kind of
be taken away from you you know and so
it kind of again lit fired me to say
okay I gotta get back to square one and
pound the pavement alright this is what
I didn't know I wanted to do this and it
was like oh this is what I want to do
now now how do i how do I get back to
where I want to be so I just would I
want to go and see every movie and cover
any junket for any outlet that would
have me and just I want to work that
Access Hollywood I worked at MSNBC and I
but I tried to in that time find my
voice because in our line of work you
can often get pushed and pulled in a
million directions that aren't authentic
to who you are and you would say we'll
ask this question or dress this way or I
know you're not into pets but will you
host a pilot for a dog game show or and
I took that time to kind of find my
voice and realize that I love movies I
love directors I love actor I love
sitting down and talking to these
creative minds like that's what I want
to do I want to cover films I want to
cover you know I want to be on set I
want to review movies I kind of found my
voice during that time now yeah the job
sometimes you have to go interview Miss
USA or you go and you interview a
Kardashian
that's fine and now it's kind of fun to
do something a little different after
I've covered movies so extensively just
so long so but during that time period I
was like I need to kind of find my voice
and so that after that MTV experience it
was kind of back to the drawing board
and reinvented myself a little bit and
then moved out to Los Angeles like many
months later and and worked at MSNBC and
NBC and freelance here and there and I
was trying to produce a movie with Ice
Cube's company and was just doing
anything that kind of just like immersed
myself in the world of film and then I
had a general meeting at the e-channel
and that place changed my life forever
I'm forever grateful of it well there's
a documentary an independent documentary
entitled my big break
Tony Sierra and you know he talks about
he interviews an agent that says that
most people in Hollywood do get some
type of 15 minutes of fame yeah but most
people aren't ready for it and they
don't seize that opportunity it's so
sure so what what is your take on that
and why do you think you were ready at
that time or that unique oh my mom it's
funny everybody asked me always you know
what advice did your dad give you on the
business but I've been lucky that my
mother has been the most supportive mom
I could ever ask for she doesn't work in
the business but she gets in she gets
people so she always says to me that
it's not so much that you know your dad
or your grandfather did anything and
pick up the phone and call anybody for
you but what they did give you was a
sense of confidence in the world of
entertainment and an understanding of it
and I see a lot of people who
understandably come into it and are
incredibly wide-eyed and that can speak
to your point of maybe not being ready
for the success that's handed to them I
will I came I was very lucky I didn't
come into it wide-eyed I grew up around
it I remember going to the set with my
dad I've ever go to see movies my dad or
different actors and filmmakers will
come by the house and we'd sit and talk
to them and I remember my dad playing in
a charity softball event when I was I
think 11 or 12 and I'd seen Saving
Private Ryan the night before and Ed
Burns was in the game with my dad and I
just went up to him as an 11 year old
and Sam talked to him for two hours and
just about the movie in about Spielberg
and who's this kid Matt Damon and viola
and just that kind of experience those
types of experiences may be really
comfortable so that one I did have an
opportunity out here I was ready for it
and I was and I was ready to build off
it and I didn't get complacent I see
also a lot of people in my line of work
they want to go to the studio read the
teleprompter when the red lights on and
then when the show is done they go home
and they have a life and they remove
themselves and I've always been
entrepreneurial and always thought a
half a warrior what's next are I'm doing
this now but how can I build off this
how can we make this better and so I was
I grew up kind of ready for it if that
makes sense it does and also having
grown up and also you said experiencing
how quickly things can be taken away
yeah what would you say is someone that
maybe is in a slump maybe they were
somewhere where they had envisioned
themselves career-wise and then the
nature of the business the rug is pulled
yeah are you and then you have to
rebuild what I thought about this a lot
during the time I was on at the movies
because that was a really high-profile
show it got me a lot of attention it got
me a lot of ink and then it was taken
away and I was like oh how what how do I
come back from this and I realized that
everybody in Hollywood everybody in
Hollywood from a lowly entertainment
reporter to Robert Downey jr. to you
know Jon Lester the former I had a
paramount everybody gets knocked down
with this business and it's how you get
up that defines your career and defines
who you are and your voice and and and
so I would say that to anybody going
through a slump everybody's been through
a son everybody Johnny Depp everybody's
been in a slump in doing research for
Penelope Cruz today when she came to
Hollywood after some success and in
Spanish language films she came out here
and had some studio flops you know some
movies that didn't really connect with
audiences and she went back and
reinvented herself and did volver and
got an Oscar nom and boom she was back
you know everybody's career is ups and
down that's what's fun about it honestly
I so so kind of
I don't know like revel in the slump
like enjoy it like that's the their your
time now to reinvent yourself and get
better at what you do and then and then
it's time for you to go back even harder
the day I was like go from at the movies
I came back to LA and I hosted Holi
shorts opening night and did a Q&A with
to me more and here's some dunks at the
DGA and I had a moment where I was like
alright they can take that away from me
but they can't take this away from me
so I'm gonna still be here but still put
myself out there then and that month
after at the movies I was everywhere
I saw every movie I was on every carpet
I was doing every interview and it just
then I met a lot of great people a lot
of people who said hey you got a raw
deal on the show whatever it was and
then then I got another job with Russell
Simmons company and I was just back in
the mix and I think you have to enjoy
you try to find some comfort or some
solace in the walls because you know
that it's only gonna go up because
everybody go get to knock down in this
business everybody everybody's one role
away everybody's one flop away you know
there's so many actors who had a moment
and then it was taken away from look it
like who recently him I was like oh look
like Matthew Modine okay he had some he
was kind of big in like the mid 90s did
it really happen for him he's in the new
Batman movie like that's crazy you know
looking Vanilla Ice talk about a guy
who's seen the ups and downs he's now
with Adam Sandler movie and has like a
huge role in it to the junket last week
and his sound MTV Awards in his back and
his doing his thing and it's like
everybody has a hue his do it yourself
show his like home improvement show is
in like season 3 and he's a book and
he's like a Koreans I don't know I'm
gonna sing be Vanilla Ice but I'm just
saying like everybody has ups and downs
so if you're going through it down it's
nothing special because everybody goes
through that everybody especially in
Hollywood you know it's like you're you
know there's no it's not like that
there's a rule book you have to follow
or like you know like if you're going to
become a dentist you have to go to
college you have to go to bed school you
have to you don't work
as an intern and it ends as on then you
come there nope there are 22 year olds
Wizkid dentists you know our
stockbrokers if you will those those
career paths have like there's some
security in that and some comfort now
but if you're in the entertainment
business in Hollywood who needs a wild
wild west so I'm on TV right now I might
not be in 3 years who knows what I'll be
doing
but if again if I stay open and meet
some good people and push myself I'm
sure I'll be fine whatever I'm doing but
I don't know where I'm gonna be two
years from now three years from now ten
years from now you know so if
everybody's career goes up and down so
anybody going through that law like
enjoy it because so it's only gonna get
better
so I say
you